so what I wanted to do here is go over
the events of Secret Wars part 5 and
again we're covering these stories as
they're released and so while there may
be large gaps between each of these
videos this is due to the fact that the
main secret war story is a monthly
series what I also want to mention is
that once Secret Wars completes we'll
come back and cover the tie ends in
order to give this well-rounded
perspective of the whole Secret Wars
event
so in part four we had talked about how
dr. strange was harboring feelings of
resentment towards doom the feelings of
strange had weren't necessarily based in
a hatred for doom but a disappointment
with how the new reality is versus how
it should have been were Duma taking the
power of the beyonders and created a
harsh world where its occupants were
tested on a daily basis following the
collapse of the multiverse strange
seemed to prefer the idea of effectively
giving life a chance to start over on
the best foot possible in addition to
this these survivors of the ultimate
universe and the survivors of the
mainstream continuity began to sort of
take sides here Miles Morales Peter
Parker Reed Richards Thor
star-lord Cyclops and black panther had
all united under the banner of dr.
strange while Thanos Namor and the Cabal
had gone their own way however the
forces of fan o's had come into conflict
with a thor core the police force a
battle world and in doing so do the
attention of dr. strangers group which
led to the appearance of doom following
the realization that the mainstream Reed
Richards was alive but because Cyclops
with the powers of the Phoenix force had
been killed by doom Doctor Strange had
whisked all the survivors away to
various locations throughout battle
world now what I want to do is it what a
deviate and I want to talk about the
death of Cyclops as the Phoenix for a
second because while this was an
impressive scene and something that I
think went unnoticed by readers is that
with Cyclops survival into battle world
followed by his death Jonathan Hickman
is effectively telling us that the
Phoenix force now exists on battleworld
more so than that at some point the
Phoenix force is going to need a new
host continuing on because Doctor
Strange saving the heroes was considered
to be an act of treason against dooms
authority and stating that doom had
ruined the chance for the survivors of
the multiversal collapse to start over
Doctor Strange refused to bring the
heroes back as a result doom had killed
dr. strange and so what we do now is we
pick up with Secret Wars issue number
five and the continuation of the story
so starting off with the funeral of dr.
strange there are a few key things here
I would like you to pay special
attention to the first is the eulogy
that's being given the unnamed man of
the Thor Court tells us that in the
beginning there was nothing and that the
great god Doom had created everything
and alongside him stood his first
disciple in the form of Doctor Strange
if you notice there's no mention of the
molecule man the third man who stood
beside doom and strange and the battle
against the beyonders in order to save
the multiverse now this is something I'd
like you to keep in the back of your
head because this will become
particularly important as we continue
with this part of the event the next
thing I'd like you to take notice of is
Franklin Richards when the funeral
proceedings complete Franklin Richards
offers a gift to the statue of dr.
strange in the form of a leaf that he
turns into a wreath now again this is
also important because Jonathan Hickman
is telling us the Franklin Richards
still has the power to work reality
furthermore because Jonathan Hickman
stories all tie into each other with the
events of Franklin Richards making
Galactus is Harold during the Future
Foundation in the mainstream continuity
it's entirely possible the dispersion of
Franklin Richards does possess the same
power now whether this power rivals that
of dr. doom is unknown but what Franklin
tells us is that he plans revenge
against whoever was the kill dr. strange
indicating that a battle will take place
somewhere along the line between
Franklin Richards and dr. doom now the
story begins to transition away a bit
and focus on Valyria Richards as a
daughter of Susan and Reed Valerio was a
character that had a level of
intelligence comparable to both her
father and Doctor Doom as such while she
expressed his feelings to doom that her
actions of having previously notified
dr. strange about the survivors of the
ultimate universe led him down the path
that resulted in his death issue remains
unaware that it was actually doom
strange but furthermore in her mind in
the mind of everyone else it is believed
that the survivors of the mainstream in
the Ultimate Universe continuities were
actually the ones who had killed strange
and so the question lingers that if doom
himself had arrived to fight alongside
dr. strange how was it that the
survivors got away while doom seems to
beat around the bush here in stating
that no one had escaped the explanation
he offers on why they've not been
captured is that in its current mindset
if you were to seek them out he would
immediately destroy them in his own
grief now while this is clearly a lie
Jonathan Hickman leaves this a little
ambiguous as to whether or not valaria
believes it and so in an effort to
distract her thoughts from dooms
involvement or for some reason or
another doom task Valyria Richards with
tracking down the survivors of the
mainstream and the Ultimate Universe
continuities now continuing on Jonathan
Hickman continues this trend of
revealing important aspects of the
events following the collapse of the
multiverse when we learn that the
molecule man Owen Reese is actually
still alive now this is perhaps the most
important aspect of the story because
this gives us some insight into how
battle will formed how it function prior
to the death of Stephen strange and how
his death will change everything going
forward now I'd like you to pay special
attention to the words Hickman uses here
devour hunger and so on while this could
simply mean that Owen Reese is quite
literally hungry for physical food the
running theory among fans is that
molecule man is set to be the new
Galactus again while this is a theory it
seems supported in the information that
follows but what Hickman does here is
seemingly retcon the creation of
everything where previously was believed
at the Enigma known as the one above all
was the driving force behind everything
in existence
what Hickman seems to be telling us here
is that the beyonders themselves had
created all things including the
multiverse in addition to this Hickman
revives a bit of consolidation regarding
the events that led up to the
multiversal collapse with the be otters
having looked at their multiverse and
making the decision to basically start
over the molecule man was created and
then split into an infinite number of
versions of himself which were all
placed in every reality across the
infinite expanse of the multiverse using
his ability to control the molecules of
all things
the Beyonder sought to destroy
version of molecule man simultaneously
which would bring an end to everything
and allow the beyonders to basically
start anew however learning other plan
doom and Owen Reese concocted their own
plan to destroy each version of Owen
Reese and were to preserve the
multiverse but a byproduct of this
action was that with each version a
molecule man that was killed in an
alternate reality the mainstream
molecule man grew more and more insane
since he was effectively losing more and
more of himself and so with time running
short dooms strange and Owen Reese
abandoned their plan and instead began
collecting molecule man from the
realities that hadn't been destroyed now
during their final battle with the
beyonders the captured versions of
molecule men were dispersed into the
beyonders and detonated like bombs and
so with the beyonders dead with their
powers still present dooms strange and
the last remaining Owen Reese captured
their power seeking to use it in order
to preserve what was left using
fragments of the world that he had
traveled during his time killing the
molecule man doomed peace these
fragments together and formed battle
world in addition to this the power of
the beyonders was simply too much for
Doom or dr. strange to control and so
using Owen Reese as a conduit the power
of the beyonders is channeled through
the molecule man and possessed by doom
however what it meant tells us is that
where dr. doom acted as the power of
battle world he was not all-knowing and
relied on dr. strange to operate as an
eyes and ears but because dr. strange is
now dead doom is virtually blind to all
things going on in battle world which is
effectively started a chain reaction
that will eventually lead to its total
destruction now transitioning back to
Valyria Richards we join with the Future
Foundation as a group that was
established in Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four the Future Foundation
operated as a group of the world's
brightest minds both young and old in
order to solve the world's problems
while the group as it exists now is
composed of a fraction of its original
population under valerie richards they
establish a couple of important things
for us the first is that everything on
battle world is composed of what they
refer to as god particles with a power
of doom
while we know this to be the power of
the beyonders the future foundation
doesn't and so they simply state that
everything on battle world is composed
of this
now while this might be a bit of a
stretch here I would be willing to go
out on a limb and say that Hickman is
telling us there rather than doomed
piecing battle world together from what
was left of the multiverse instead all
of the realities that exist on battle
world were created by doom using the
power of the beyonders and furthermore
as it stated here where dr. Doom's power
was rooted in the beyonders the power
Stephen strange was rooted in magic as a
result when Stephen strange wished the
survivors of the mainstream and Ultimate
Universe continuity is away and was
subsequently killed by doom the machines
of the Future Foundation registered to
spikes of energy won by doom and won by
Doctor Strange using the timeline of
Wendy's energy spike the group seems to
come to the realization that doom killed
strange but as Valerius states all
information gathered on the
investigation will stay with the group
and so as we bring this issue of secret
Wars to a close we find fan OHS facing
the shield which separates the rest of
battle world from the Marvel Zombies and
Ultron indicating that Thanos intends to
use these forces for his own ends with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will catch you guys
later peace